[Aplausos]
[Música]
situado en el golfo pérsico qatar es un
país de poco más de 10.000 kilómetros
cuadrados para que os hagáis una idea es
algo así como la mitad del salvador o
siete veces más pequeño que panamá pues
bien cuando en 1971 obtuvo su
independencia del reino unido qatar era
un lugar remoto hostil y pobre muy pobre
de hecho era uno de los territorios más
pobres de todo el imperio británico y no
era para menos la península de qatar un
lugar donde las temperaturas superan en
verano ojo los 50 grados y donde
prácticamente todo está cubierto por
desierto es sin duda uno de los lugares
menos habitables de toda la tierra o al
menos lo era porque hoy amigos qatar es
el país más rico de todo el planeta tal
cual como lo escucháis los ciudadanos de
este pequeño país disfrutan de una renta
per cápita real de más de 125 mil
dólares casi tres veces más que la de
francia y cinco veces más que la de
chile por ejemplo
[Música]
el que un día fue un país prácticamente
despoblado un país que apenas lograba
subsistir con la pesca es hoy una
especie de caja fuerte del tío gilito en
españa o del tío rico en latinoamérica
el gobierno de qatar tiene hoy
inversiones y propiedades por todo el
mundo es la cuna de al yazira el medio
de comunicación árabe más importante y
su capital doha es todo un despliegue de
rascacielos centros comerciales de
automóviles de lujo una mezcla entre
mónaco y las vegas' pero sin juego ni
alcohol no hay lugar para la sobriedad
todo es ostentoso enorme y brillante en
doha durante todo este proceso de cambio
qatar ha pasado de ser un oscuro refugio
para fundamentalistas islámicos que
incluso en la mismísima arabia saudita
se consideraban radicales a ser hoy tal
vez el país más abierto de todo el
oriente medio
con la excepción de dubai y aunque por
supuesto este último emirato no es un
país el caso es que la soja de hoy
podemos encontrar universidades
internacionales o por ejemplo la
conocida como church city un complejo
con iglesias protestantes ortodoxas y
católicas como es el caso de la iglesia
de nuestra señora del rosario' seis mil
personas abarrotaron nueva iglesia en
qatar para su consagración llegados a
este punto creo que está clara la
pregunta que podemos hacernos cómo ha
conseguido catar semejante
transformación veámoslo
[Música]
la bendición del gas natural licuado en
otros vídeos hemos visto algunas claves
de por qué en muchos países son tan
ricos pues bien en el caso de qatar
digamos que las claves son mucho más
simples y se resumen en dos elementos
petróleo y sobre todo gas natural
muchísimo gas natural sí así es
decepcionado pues esperad un momento
porque la historia tiene su mira en la
década de los 40 se descubrieron los
primeros yacimientos de petróleo qatarí
cuando éste comenzó a explotarse
seriamente allá por los 60 las cosas en
este país tan pobre por aquel entonces
comenzaron a mejorar pero no tanto
lo cierto amigos es que no fue hasta
inicios de los 70 cuando la cell
descubrió el gran tesoro de este país el
campo norte el mayor yacimiento de gas
natural del mundo claro que por aquel
entonces el gas natural no valía mucho
si me explico por aquel entonces el gas
sólo podía ser transportado por
gasoductos por tuberías y qatar estaba
demasiado lejos de cualquier lugar que
pudiera consumir este recurso así que
bueno cómo decirlo digamos que la propia
cell se olvidó rápido de este
descubrimiento pero las cosas no siempre
iban a ser así para nada en 1995 el
antiguo emir hamad bin khalifa al-thani
que por cierto aplicó hace relativamente
poco en 2013 dio un golpe de estado
aprovechando que su padre estaba de
viaje en suiza pues bien
hamad bin khalifa al-thani llegó al
poder con una idea muy clara el futuro
de qatar pasaba por el gas había que
explotar esas inmensas reservas y dicho
el nuevo emir apostó muy fuerte por una
tecnología que por aquel entonces no
estaba ni muy desarrollada ni muy
extendida la licuefacción es decir la
capacidad de llevar el gas natural a una
forma líquida para poder así
transportarlo como si de petróleo se
tratase en grandes barcos para ello
amigos hay que enfriar y mantenerlas a
una temperatura de 161 grados bajo cero
casi nada pues bien el qatar del nuevo
emir decidió precisamente invertir
enormes cantidades de recursos en
impulsar el desarrollo de esta
tecnología y poder usarla a gran escala
gracias a ello qatar está hoy en la
vanguardia y es el mayor exportador
mundial de gas natural licuado gracias a
esta tecnología
qatar puede explotar intensamente sus
reservas de gas las terceras mayores de
todo el mundo de hecho tres cuartas
partes del gas qatarí fluyeron el año
pasado a países asiáticos como china
india corea del sur o japón su mayor
cliente
y no sólo eso los complejos industriales
que ha desarrollado qatar son tan
grandes trabajan a tal escala que el
país ha conseguido tener los menores
costes de extracción y licuación por
ejemplo llenar un metanero de gas
natural licuado es cuatro veces más
económico en qatar que los mismísimos
eeuu este amigos es el gran secreto de
este pequeño y rico país ahora bien como
sabéis y ejemplos nos sobran además de
saber extraer los recursos para que no
nos ocurra lo que angola oaa venezuela
hay que saber utilizar el dinero que se
genera en esta línea además de esta
primera apuesta inversora la riqueza de
qatar tiene algunas claves adicionales
[Música]
qatar powers
desde qué hamad bin khalifa al-thani
llegó al poder en 1995 las cosas han
cambiado mucho en sus 18 años amigos al
frente del país la población de qatar se
multiplicó por cuatro al tiempo que se
convirtió en el país más rico del
planeta
[Música]
vamos que a este mir le sobran motivos
para sacar pecho pero sigamos el caso es
que qatar comenzó a generar muchísimos
recursos económicos y que pensáis que
hacen con todos ellos pues a pesar de lo
que nos pudiera parecer fundamentalmente
los han invertido dentro y fuera del
país
así es qatar ha constituido la autoridad
de inversiones de qatar un gran fondo
para invertir dinero por todo el mundo
se le conoce como captar power porque
amigos este fondo cuenta con más de 330
mil millones de dólares ojo porque la
población de qatar es de algo menos de 3
millones de habitantes pero de estos
apenas unos 300.000 son ciudadanos son
qataríes así que echas cuentas de a
cuánto sale cada uno si a más de un
millón pues bien el caso es que este
gran fondo tiene propiedades por todo el
mundo
por ejemplo en 2016 qatar fue el cuarto
mayor inversor en oficinas en todo eeuu
tan sólo en manhattan ha invertido en
los dos últimos años cinco mil millones
de dólares en proyectos inmobiliarios
incluida la compra de una parte del
empire state building en londres gran
parte de la city pertenece a este país
de hecho en la capital británica es
posible vivir trabajar comprar y
alojarse exclusivamente en propiedades
de qatar oficinas apartamentos hoteles
y también tiene participaciones muy
importantes en muchas multinacionales
muy conocidas por citar sólo unos pocos
ejemplos que adaptar es uno de los
mayores accionistas de empresas como
volkswagen iberdrola berkeley
tiffany cel o incluso el gigante rose
net la empresa petrolera del gobierno
ruso en el siguiente gráfico podéis ver
cómo a medida que la producción de gas y
petróleo se ha incrementado también ha
crecido la inversión del país en el
extranjero y por supuesto también dentro
del propio qatar se están invirtiendo
grandes cantidades de recursos decenas
de miles de millones para autopistas
puertos aeropuertos centros de
investigación centros financieros
etcétera etcétera el objetivo que el día
de mañana
estas inversiones sean capaces de suplir
los ingresos del petróleo y el gas
natural claro que hasta que este gran
negocio se termine aún queda mucho
no hay ningún analista que pueda decir
cuándo va a caer la demanda de gas para
el petróleo hay gente que ve el pico de
demanda en 2030 otros en 2042 pero para
el gas la demanda está constantemente en
crecimiento puede amigos que esta
vocación por invertir y no gastar el
dinero generado por los recursos
naturales sea una de las grandes
diferencias con otros países también muy
ricos en recursos naturales es fácil
gastar pero hay que pensar en el futuro
no os parece
sí
[Música]
por la independencia efectiva cuando
hamad bin khalifa al-thani llegó al
poder también tenía otra idea muy clara
que atar debía ganar peso internacional
veréis durante años qatar fue controlada
de facto por arabia saudita y el nuevo
emir no se quitaba de la cabeza a la
invasión de kuwait por parte de irak si
qatar quería sobrevivir necesitaba ganar
entidad propia peso internacional de
otra forma cualquier conflicto con riad
podría acabar con la independencia del
país además ahora si el gas natural
podía pagar las facturas
así que se buscaron alianzas
internacionales por ejemplo cuando en
2003 arabia saudita invitó a eeuu a
sacar sus tropas del país
qatar no dudó un momento en ofrecerse
como destino ni tampoco dudó en gastarse
mil millones de dólares en construir las
bases
hoy más de 10.000 soldados
estadounidenses están en el país la
mayor base de operaciones de la gran
potencia norteamericana en la región
podemos decir que qatar contrató la
mejor póliza de seguros
por otro lado se puso en marcha al
yazira con el objetivo de ganar
influencia algo en lo que tuvieron mucho
mucho éxito como ya vimos aquí en visual
política y también desarrollaron una
intensa política exterior para ganar
influencia internacional así qatar no
dudó en apoyar las primaveras árabes o
acercarse de algún modo a ir a por
ejemplo había que ganar apoyo social y
político
[Música]
el bloqueo pues bien toda esta
estrategia política puso furiosos a sus
vecinos de arabia saudita y emiratos
árabes como respuesta a estos países
anunciaron el pasado junio de 2017 un
salvaje bloqueo contra qatar acusándole
de apoyar a grupos fundamentalistas y
terroristas increíble
arabia saudita haciendo semejante
acusación ver para creer
es verdad que qatar tiene algún agujero
negro al fin y al cabo es una monarquía
absolutista pero es un buen aliado de
occidente especialmente de eeuu y uno de
los países más aperturistas de la región
lo cierto amigos es que el boicot tenía
como objetivo terminar con toda esa
estrategia internacional de qatar y como
decirlo de ponerles en su sitio pero la
verdad todo esto del bloqueo está siendo
un gran fracaso
por un lado ha mostrado que la posición
de riad no es tan fuerte muy pocos
países se han sumado incluso kuwait y
omán no lo han secundado por otro ha
impulsado los lazos de qatar con turquía
e incluso irán y desde luego catar ha
demostrado tener músculo para hacer
frente a esta situación
es más tratar ha anunciado que acelerará
algunos planes de apertura
por ejemplo para atraer inversiones
extranjeras o para hacer más fácil
obtener la residencia permanente pero de
todo esto hablaremos en otro vídeo eso
sí para terminar aclaremos una cuestión
qatar tiene muchos puntos negros las
condiciones laborales de muchos de los
trabajadores de países pobres la
situación de la mujer o por supuesto la
falta de democracia y además el modelo
aún tiene que demostrar que puede
funcionar sin el gobierno porque a
diferencia de dubai aquí el protagonismo
no lo ha tenido la iniciativa privada
sino la pública entre otras cosas por
esto dubai sigue por encima en casi
todos los parámetros pero amigos no
sería justo no reconocer otros avances y
puntos fuertes como el ahorro y la
inversión productiva o la apertura en
fin turno para ti quién crees que ganará
el pulso entre los países del golfo lo
ganará arabia saudita o lo ganará qatar
déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios
y también en esta encuesta si te ha
gustado el vídeo
y suscríbete a visual polític si aún no
lo has hecho un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Aplausos]
[Música]